je dis aux harkis à leurs enfants à voix
haute et solennelle
que la république a alors contracté à
leur égard une dette
aux combattants
je veux dire notre reconnaissance
nous n'oublierons pas
aux combattants abandonnés à leur
famille qu'ils ont subi les camps la
prison le déni
je demande pardon
nous n'oublierons pas
depuis la république s'est ressaisi
elle a reconnu les sacrifices consentis
et les souffrances infligées
le temps des non dits le temps du déni
était révolue
la france s'est engagée aux côtés des
harkis sur la voie de la vérité de la
justice elle a agi voter des lois et des
soutenu entamé un travail de mémoire que
nous avons intensifié ces dernières
années
elle honore les harkis et leurs enfants
leur histoire leur résilience leur
combat et aujourd'hui encore je
remettrai dans quelques instants les
insignes de nos ordres nationaux de la
légion d'honneur et du mérite à monsieur
salle abdelkrim qui a versé son sang
pour la france et qui a été citée deux
fois au combat à madame bornia tarall
fille de harki qui s'est engagé sans
relâche pour la diversité l'égalité des
chances et l'identité
mais il s'agit désormais
de réparer autant qu'il est possible
ces déchirures
déchirure de l'histoire
que vous portez dans votre chair
le souvenir des harkis l'honneur des
harkis doit être gravé dans la mémoire
nationale
cette histoire
là raconte-t-on nous l'enseignant et
nous continuerons d'en penser les plaies
tant qu'elles ne seront pas refermée par
des paroles de vérité des gestes de
mémoire
et d acte de justice
c'est pourquoi le gouvernement portera
avant la fin de l'année un projet
visant à inscrire dans le marbre de nos
lois la reconnaissance et la réparation
à l'égard des harkis
je m'y engage